Before we go any further,
I want to show you something
that every web developer needs to know,
developer tools.
This may seem a bit overwhelming
at first but I promise,
you'll learn to love them.
I'm going to open up Google Chrome and
visit one of my favorite websites,
ESPN.com.
Now, I could demonstrate this
using another web browser
that has developer tools.
But for this demonstration,
I'm going to use Google Chrome.
If I right click this page and select
the inspect option in the drop down,
it opens Google's developer tools.
Remember how I said it would seem
overwhelming, I wasn't kidding,
there's a ton of stuff here.
To keep this simple, I'm only
going to focus on the elements tab.
But know that the other tabs can
give you a much closer look into how
a website is built, how it performs,
and what's going on behind the scenes.
Let's try something out.
If you notice, under this elements tab,
we have some HTML.
This is actually the HTML for
the page we're currently viewing.
This is more obvious when I
start hovering over elements
in HTML because Google Chrome highlights
the corresponding elements on the page.
That's pretty sweet.
And if I click on one of these elements,
then in the bottom right hand corner,
I can see what styles
are being applied to it.
That's even better.
It looks like the element I've
selected's got a lot going on.
Let's try unchecking one of these
properties to see what happens.
Whoa, did you see that?
The background color of
the navigation just disappeared.
That's because I change the CSS
being applied to this element.
By unchecking the box, I removed the
background color this div normally uses.
Let's try another one.
I'll select one of these articles.
And let's try changing
the background color.
Wow.
Now these articles look like
they're floating on the page.
Each article just runs
up against the next one.
And it's not easy anymore to
tell where one starts and
where the next one begins.
Now don't worry.
These changes aren't permanent.
And they're only visible
to me on this computer.
If I refresh the page,
everything returns back to normal.
As you can tell,
I could spend all day playing around
with the styling on this page.
But hopefully, what is more obvious
to you is that you see how beneficial
developer tools can be
to a web developer.
They literally tell us exactly
how the page is built.
You can see both the HTML and
the CSS that is creating the page
that you see in the browser.